my life was kind of rough I had an awful
battle down I said my life is fragile
like the game I guarantee the name is
what they had done to the work and
everything would change
Zippity helping field yet that's what I
wanna be a patient hell the trick
[Music]
team with Gary Vee good morning good
morning good morning good morning give
me one second I'm doing a little
something I'm doing a little something
give me one second one second I'm sorry
everyone will be having a good morning
just trying to get something taken care
of on my computer one second everybody
this is the sports cards edition which
is really fun
we tweeted out last week I've got some
good questions I'm sure hopefully I can
answer to them a lot of things I know in
the sports card world's a lot of things
I don't so we'll see how that goes okay
we're in the business there
Dustin how are you this morning it's
great I love that I think is a good good
answer all right let's get right into
the show cool no yes I'm very good I'm
super well brother what's cooking
another man name's David Richardson Lana
I'm in Buckhead Atlanta and there's a
sports card I'm like gonna be like a
squirrel right now so you just gonna
have to kind of you know Naomi I'm I'm a
squirrel don't worry go ahead thank you
man
I mean you've done so much just for my
mental like I'm the oldest of three boys
just with my mom like great parenting
and genetics
I was just blessed with a lot of the
self-awareness patience practicality
frugality and you know when you get out
in the real world you're being thrown
all this different stuff and I kind of
ran into you in my 2017-2018 and I
didn't really know how to articulate
contextualize a lot of the stuff that
came natural to me and you just like
really reinforced him and it made it
sound you know it makes so much sense
you used to talk about this analogy
about being the shield you know and say
you were kind of that shield for me do
you talked about
you know being the shield in high school
for bullies and stuff and so like when I
was trying to like you know with three
four deep convince my friends to let
three four deep live humbly I'm driving
like a $2,000 car with no a/c for the
last three years look you know just
saving my money patience work ethic
taking pay cuts to jump jobs to try and
you like I mean you just inspired all
that man and when all the outsides like
what are you doing you know you got
something going on you you know taking a
pay cut leaving this job you've been you
know advancing in I was just like Gary
Gary Gary Gary so thank you bye thank
you so much for that I want to thank you
so much for that dude like back in
September ask Gary B's you had like
Michael Ovitz Scott Belsky my favorite
that Beth Comstock where she's talking
about being Ted Turner at 33 coming out
the bathroom and that was like her
clinic and I'm like here 26 I hate my
job I'm just like perspective dude so
gotta get out of the way man thank you
for saying that David what's your
question let me get in my tunnel so
anyways I got into sports cards by
January February been crazy to artwork
like I draw and you know a little
creative so like the artwork resonated
with me and you know kind of just like
the mancave flash but you know guys like
me are 4050 I'd be cool to have like a
Katy rookie card and stuff so my
question is is eBay evolving with the
market and I think you would be the new
guy I you know is eBay evolving yes I
think he basil bobbing anybody's paying
eighty bees a big company and and pays
attention and I think if you look at
eBay's history over the last 20 years
when a certain genre gets serious they
get more detailed and they're already
evolving like the search based on the
grading and things of that nature so I
think I conveyed above I expect you know
stock X to evolve and I and you see all
sorts of startups coming up I've been
reached out by so many venture
capitalists and and founders of like I'm
doing this thing in sports card so you
know again a lot of people like Gary B
you you brought all these people and you
know look yes I have some people
following me and some people came but
this was happening long before me the
reason I got back in is because I
observed how many people were coming
into the space and so the space is
getting big it's a collectors and
and entrepreneurs space it's always been
you know people that think it's an
investment people that sell them people
that buy them the card companies
manipulate that with the limited numbers
and things that nature if that's the
manipulation from the top or the order
structure for the top whatever where do
you want to use as far as the next guy
you know I I rarely have an opinion of
like the next guy firm like on the
record which is why once every six
months I'll share what I think whether
it was Devin Booker or Cunha or I
thought the Durant was an opportunity
you know I I don't have a there's a lot
of great players there's a lot of young
good basketball players but they're so
young so I don't have an official point
of view on that right now but I think
the 60 game baseball season is gonna
capture a lot of attention because it's
limited games I think baseball will be
more fun it's gonna be like playoffs the
whole time you hope that they can get
through it cuz COBIT is still looming
you know like we'll see how that goes
but that's where I'm at
yeah man I said one more question was uh
outside of rookie cards like cards of
guys going into like a season where
they're about to do some stuff so like
like 2015 LeBron James card where he's
gonna like go on to win like come down
from 3-1 to win or like a third year
paddy Mahone's card where he's got like
yep MVP season stats on the bag
historically no historically not as much
upside but but anything's possible now
that there's so much new energy things
get read yeah you know when I was when I
was a kid the upper deck
you know Shaquille O'Neal was the axial
rookie card now it's the bean team you
know things do change you know when I
was a kid baseball cards dominated
basketball cards are not like so things
do change
I don't see that right now I also
noticed on your Shack excuse me on your
LeBron that you had it in a case that's
by like a grading company cut yeah yes I
really no no I got all psays that was
early on awesome
David thank you so much man good luck
thank you bro man thank you so much
god bless
let's keep it going
come on something guy how are you going
on man how are you I'm great how's you
how's your family oh well thank you for
asking
awesome so right before I get into the
sports card question just want to say
I've been following you for a couple
years
obviously gained so much insight when it
comes to the business the life but I
think really the biggest thing I've
gotten from you is like this profound
massive appreciation and gratefulness
for my parents just how I was raised
everything that they sacrificed and like
it's just been such a huge part of my
development I'm in my early 20s I'm 24
and like I feel like now on my mom's
side like every other conversation I'm
just like hey by the way like thanks for
[ __ ] making me that was awesome and
then like was my dad I'm working for his
business you know really like chasing
the legacy thing like he I got three
brothers
he started it in the 90s said [ __ ] doing
the corporate [ __ ] I'm gonna figure this
out myself trying to build a business
somehow making that work to create a
successful business with kids and a wife
like it blows my mind so like now I'm in
this pursuit like doing everything I can
to give back to him also selfishly
learning how to do business so I can try
to do something myself later on so I
think I kind of want to do that seeing
you do it kind of gave me more of like a
framework bro so I pretended that I wish
nothing but the best
appreciate it so get into the cards um
obviously been funny for a couple years
you used to do sports cards when I was a
kid but like I was just putting them in
my [ __ ] tire of my bike like I wasn't
like hustling with them or anything
started looking into it like a couple
months ago followed your advice really
started putting the time and going
through Twitter blow up forums eBay all
that jazz finally had to pull the
trigger on something so I bought like at
89 score Deion Sanders rookie because I
want to flip it it's the best and the
hair I actually think it's funny I you
know I'm not as passionate about you
know the investment opportunities in
football though they'll be they're just
not as much a basketball soccer
wrestling believe it or not is somewhere
I'm hot on but footballs my favorite
sport and Deion is just a guy I am one
of those I one of those as well in my
collection and his tweets like him off
like what he's tweeting and like putting
out every day is so great it's like
amazing so you look at Deion you
look at Alex Rodriguez you look at
Dwyane Wade there are athletes that are
staying extremely relevant post their
career each which benefits their sports
card no question huge and it's doubled
since like April which is nuts I mean
the whole I mean right now the market
everything everything anyway okay so
anyway which is which is scary by the
way right like you know it doesn't seem
real well I think it can be real if you
have that much demand and there is only
so much supply it's not like a stock
that can split it's not like the
American dollar that they can keep
[ __ ] the other thing so there is a
lot of validity to it and I do think
alternative investing is coming like
people are just putting money in
different places and sports is so our
culture and an entrepreneurship huge
such our culture just a truth and so it
could be but but I think it's really
important you know there's so much
excitement as a lot of people watching
right now that watch tea with Gary Vee
that don't follow that part of my life
or that yeah this is not like a gold
rush you have to be very careful very
educated there's a lot to learn it's
very complicated this is a 50 to 200
hour blowout forums Twitter you know
discord groups YouTube there's a lot to
learn you know there's a lot of oh geez
that have been in at the whole time
which even have who have way more
context than I do a lot of people that
are just in it for the Hobby so they
don't like the selling and and flipping
out yeah and so I've empathy I respect I
I respected a ton make they you know a
lot of them really don't like me because
I represent that's a no Jason
but you know it's listen I respect it if
you're in a hobby you know and you're
there because you you know for the hobby
of it you know it's kind of like me with
fantasy sports like I don't like when my
friends play fantasy football because
I'm in it for the Jets part but I don't
get to charge or tell them how to live
their life but I also understand that
the hate and the negativity I'm
empathetic to it I really understand
yeah it just I just wish that people
understood how much bigger than me it
was it was it was what panini and tops
did with limitations in one of ones
that's yeah it's you know so nonetheless
so what can I answer so okay so I get
that
and I use next door for like marketing
for our company because it's kind of
local it's kind of you know and I just
like [ __ ] I'm just gonna post
something like hey getting back into the
Hobby like if you were your kid has any
old cards you want to get rid of like
let me know this really nice lady hits
me up she's like hey my father-in-law
like he's got this collection he doesn't
care about anymore sends me a couple
boxes I can see it's like you know some
vintage stuff
I'm like all right [ __ ] it I'll take a
little gamble drop a couple hundred
bucks start going crazy to 3 a.m. and I
just flipping through these cards
looking them up I start to notice I'm
like where are these studs at like where
are these Quinn rookies like I'm not
seeing them I start saying like is he
like hiding home like this yeah I'm like
another set where all this stuff is she
sends me a text on Tuesday like hey just
spent all weekend cleaning out my attic
like got a bunch of [ __ ] like I want to
send it over to you to take a look she
sends me these pictures my head almost
explodes I'm looking through these
pictures I'm seeing just Steve young
rookies montana's Glenn's like across
the board end up going back and forth
but there's been a couple thousand now I
got this huge set of stuff I've looked
through like five percent of it already
know if I sold some of this stuff raw
make my money back now I'm like getting
super second top go ahead Dustin I want
to answer Todd's questions so make sure
you hold on to that later go ahead
brother so like some really sick stuff
and like a lot of potential reselling
that could happen from this that's what
I want to do haven't really been able to
flip through because I'm scared to death
of like putting my finger on the cards
like should I have gloves on I don't
have any sleeves right now because
they're backorder not top loader so I
can't even look do this [ __ ] I'm like
barely creeping through it so like I
know that I gotta get inventory together
like in and but like my next question is
how should I diversify this [ __ ] should
I send it all the PSA should I split it
up like seventy or PSA and then shred
yeah you know I think look Peter wrong
you know I think all of it works he
could sell raw you could you know you
know I'm very under educated on grading
you know I missed that euro when I was a
kid so I can't look at a card and really
know the difference between a 10 and a 9
which is crazy you say that like I was
saying like in our tweet I'm like how
you've looked at how many cards are
these oh yeah are you that good yeah so
yeah it's I looked at him but when I was
a kid in the 80s like centering it was
corners increases much more than
centering centering emerged later with
as the emergence of great I didn't grew
up in the grading era so you know and
listen
I'm struggling for time for family you
know nonprofit yeah
justice businesses like you know this is
a great escape for me but I'm never
gonna be a greater which makes me happy
because then people the 15 year old me
would have been the best grader and that
kid's gonna make money on me not being
able to rape so I think you can sell raw
yeah I think PSA I'm a that bgs and SGC
are real players I personally like the
SGC case a lot cuz it's black you know
that's what's going on or what yeah go
ahead
sorry than a rub like what I was
thinking like I feel like everybody's
saying what the suc like I love how this
lab looks like how do we know that PSA
is not gonna come out and like offer hey
my multicolored slabs alright this is
what the ten case looks like that's what
the nine and they might they might and
that might you know we also don't know
if the three best creators that emerge
as kids right now go to SGC or start GGG
you don't know anything our big player
comes in and says hey this is what I
miss look sick
LeBron or something what if what if the
card companies only slap when they ship
down what if in six years tops is like
your packs are slapped anything can
happen and that's why people have to be
careful and thoughtful and mix between
diversifying mix between if you actually
want it as a hobby saving things like if
you want to do it as a business take
your profits sometimes a lot of people
get greedy they're like all the LeBrons
to ten thousand it's going to twenty
five thousand but if you bought it for
three thousand that's seven thousand
dollars a problem that's nothing to
sneeze that age so you know it's just
all a mix it's all normal business I
appreciate I'm excited
good it's a lot of fun and you can keep
enjoying it take care
time Kelly asks do you see the collapse
in the market like what happened in
early 90s second coming the junk era
Todd I think there is an inevitability
to that you know the card companies are
in the business of making cards so
panini you know and I don't know any
details about this but like I know they
made a lot more prism basketball this
year than they did last the year before
and the year before dad in the year
before that so you know yes I mean if
you know with next year's basketball
with with you know lamellar ball is 5x
what just happens I on and that's the
apex moment and then the debt the
downside interest of collect of clipping
and business goes away yeah I mean
there's there
Ben IRA's like ups and downs and sports
cards always just like real estate just
like a stock market there there will be
a dip and I do think that the
overproduction right now
the production is going to be very very
high because it stops and paninis
interests to do that upper deck sleeps
you know interest because that's their
business and people need to be extremely
mindful of that let's keep it going do
you pronounce it Jana Jana Jana Jana
such a pleasure yeah
I'm from Belgium and I first want to
thank you for all the enjoy it and it
has really changed my life I'm going to
start a marketing agency today and I
wouldn't have the courage if it wasn't
for you thank you I'm graduating in
September from University and I had a
question about sports cards especially
in Europe because I don't think it's
that popular in Europe correct me if I'm
wrong soccer soccer stickers are very
popular soccer cards are getting very
very popular and and I think actually
Europe is impacting America because
don't forget panini is a European
company yeah there's I'm seeing
something happening with basketball
stickers in the America that is
completely based on the hype among Bop a
and and your European stickers I think
Europe is honest on the football side is
exploding and I think we'll have a very
it's already having a good run and it
will continue basketball football and
America are incredibly American
basketball has the most European you
know love and I do think basketball
cards in Europe are starting to gain so
I am seeing it happen in Europe but very
much still your football a.k soccer in
America yeah yeah and I also saw you
talking about Pokemon cards do you think
that could work too because that is very
popular in Europe you know it's really
interesting what how I'm going through
a Pokemon right now I didn't grow up
with Pokemon my brother did AJ and he
loves them and he knows them and he was
in that era I'm enjoying learning about
Pokemon cards right now I'm just
starting to get really serious I bought
my first pretty expensive Pokemon card
and I'm enjoying it it's like fun it's
like bringing out the kid in me so I'm a
very big fan of Pokemon I'm unbelievably
undereducated I know nothing very little
just started the process of the market
but I'm learning quickly and yes I think
Pokemon and soccer is a great play if
you want to enjoy and try it out and
test it out I also feel like it but you
bet I mean I buy a ton of cards from
Europe on eBay I actually think that's
the opportunity I think it's not as
popular but there's not as many sellers
and there is demand growing so there's
II I actually have been talking to a lot
of European kids who are and
and characters who've been doing great
because of that so don't be discouraged
by that work for free work for low get
clients you have to get clients and that
is the first step to many people try to
start a marketing agency and have this
price and don't know how to sell and six
months later they have no clients so at
all costs get clients take care yourself
Dustin you you know have you bought any
sports cards yet no but I just busted
out my old ones here tell me something
the garbage I already know their garbage
because okay you said they're like it's
from the 93 94 era Hakeem Olajuwon over
here are you are you gonna get in are
you gonna buy a couple little things I'm
more interested in Pokemon because I
just feel like no I just feel like some
reason like it's forever
yeah they don't get hurt you don't
forget about them it's the same reason I
like comic books a lot like I'm uh I'm
definitely starting my education comic
books again - I went through this when I
was in cards
but um we went we I mean for anyone
that's trying to get into this we just
want like me and my girlfriend just
watch like a five-minute video last
night and found out is they're all trash
so it's all homework and make sure you
watch a third video to confirm its
chucat trash and then go to ebay
completed items like get real you know
just don't take it on one yeah yeah no I
didn't I went on eBay and researched it
and happy oh hi Gary how are ya I'm well
how are you I'm good thank you so much
I've been following you for three years
now I love that thank you
Sports Clinton Sports flicks for the
best Keith go ahead right field what can
I help you with all right tell me why is
the NBA cards going up so much cuz it
seems like the top players are going up
like five to six hundred bucks this week
I think the MBA is by far the most
popular global league I think that once
baseball said they were coming back it
gave people a lot of confidence that the
NBA was gonna come back you know
the hobby is extremely hot right now
like you know I keep again I keep I keep
I understand why people like you yeah
are you bringing all these people up but
like I keep reading every day like
profiles of sports card shops and
telesco and Iowa like it's just
happening it was happening before I even
said one peep about it so I think um I
think it's a it's a really interesting
time and I think basketball are the
superheroes
I mean LeBron and staff and giannis and
they're just so much more famous to
people than trout and Bryce Harper and a
cunha you know and even more famous than
Patrick McCombs and Kyler Murray and you
know Tom not Tom Brady but like you know
what I mean it's just the NBA everyone
knows their everyone knows who they are
football players wear helmets right
baseball doesn't have exposure like that
and it's just it's just so obvious that
it's an NBA soccer world and then you
started looking at things like Pokemon
for sure and then wrestling I'm very
bullish on they're just not a lot of
supply and there's a small passionate
demand group so and and there's plenty
of opportunity for baseball prospects
because that's fun and baseball is the
iconic so you know I'm from Edmonton
Canada and I think I think it crashed
but you can keep going okay I'm from
Edmonton Canada at want to ask Gary hey
boy labeling so I'm promoting Canada
you're supposed to come in March cold
best city in Canada can't wait till you
can't wait either
now what do you think of hockey cards
McDavid went for lots on Saturday and
his rookie card is doing really well I
bought that one that was the first one I
bought after listening to you yeah I you
know I uh mcDavid's an all-time talent I
I think hockey reminds me of wrestling a
little bit in that it's a small
passionate group it is super not popular
in America the league right now
unfortunately and so um I'm not educated
enough to really answer that question
for you because I've done zero hockey
you know I bought some Gretzky's I
bought some yeah let me use cuz they're
just all time for me and that's fun but
I feel like I feel like hockey's got a
tougher road but has a small incredible
passionate community if you're looking
at it from an investment standpoint but
they still will go up because the whole
market is so hot and then and then if
you love it and for the Hobby people
it's like a no-brainer because it's just
one of the best leagues I mean the 94
Rangers team is one of my favorite
things of all time and so you know I
bought a bunch of Brian Leetch rookie
cards I'm not expecting those to go
through the roof but that's the hobby
part of me so that's how I think you
need to think about it and what about
the other night you had said you stayed
up till 2:00 a.m. by and Penny Hardaway
where are you buying these cards 500 of
them Oh Tim Hardaway Tim Hartley senior
eBay you guys saw a lot of tomorrow
that's when you know you're degenerate
it's 2:00 a.m. and I'm buying 500 copies
of a Tim Hardaway flee or 1990 rookie
card at 85 cents hoping it's gonna go to
five dollars you know it's it's just so
funny and just enjoying it too because
you know Tim was a
Travel my Knicks I loved him when he was
in Golden State obviously son played for
the Knicks so there's a lot of love that
goes along with the business stuff for
me which is why it's like a win-win like
when not if when the market goes down in
the macro I'm gonna be happy I have
these things and then I can't wait for
it to have this moment again in 15 years
you know so you know you have to know
what you're getting into
how ha how long do you think you'll stay
hot nobody should nobody knows
I'd be completely guessing but I don't
think it's over you know I don't think
we're in the in hockey terms I don't
think we're in the last five minutes of
the third period you know I think we
might be somewhere in between the first
and second intermission you know but you
know in between period one and two like
it's I think it's I believe it's fairly
early still I am worried about the
global economy I think once we get back
to normal post Co vid and the stimulus
checks are gone and real life kicks in
and debt kicks in and you know social
unrest in the US and the election like
if somebody said to me that the market
started declining in December you know
November I wouldn't be surprised
I wouldn't be a little phrase I mean I
wouldn't be shocked I'd be a little
surprised because the momentum is so
clear so clear heading in one direction
that I think it plays out for a little
while and you look at things like
cryptocurrency and real estate like one
thing that I try to talk to like people
when I have a long conversation like
look it's gonna get feverishly hot what
No
are you still there Ralph yo is any1
still there and when when when it comes
back down when it comes back down it's
likely to be at a higher plane than it
is today or or where it was a year ago
do you know what I mean it's not going
back to three years ago
so anyway right I wish you well brother
okay take care buddy bye bye
I don't know if it's just my end but I
think your keep crashing Gary I don't
know well okay I'm not the only one I
was not prepared for this frozen this
year
all right everyone sending me text now
saying it's crashing check out my card
[Laughter]
all right well I couldn't bring on I
guess
I'll bring on Alex
okay us now everything's falling apart
it happens I've been with my zoomtext
stuff before I might you know so let's
see if there's any good question or can
you answer this question from Jim minty
if the hobby is so hot right now is a
good time to take profits all right
probably is a good time so I'm starting
trying to realize that it's an internet
issue that my parents I'm gonna have to
figure this out otherwise I apologize
for everybody thank god I've dust them
to hold it down how are you my friend
what's your name I'm good I'm Alex Alex
take you four five on Twitter's awesome
how are you
I'm really good man oh gee how were
those og collector guys I'm basically
trying to figure out selling to fund my
hobby
don't use don't use family money
anything like that get into debt or
anything just so I can really enjoy and
I've been collecting since the early 90s
got a lot of iconic server keys like
Jeter 93 he you know ESPYs type stuff
you know her fetus in type stuff so I've
been getting familiar with eBay recently
of course
but I'm kind of worrying if the other
tips on like you know using discord for
example yeah I mean this Court has got a
ton of great groups as you know Twitter
is has a great active community you know
the forum's Instagram chat groups
there's definitely places where you can
really find some great communities where
you don't have to go through the eBay
platform stock ex is a place look Tom C
there's so much there's so many card
shows you know I'll be honest with you I
secretly think one of the biggest
reasons I want to do this is cuz a card
shows like I don't know if I had a
better time in my life in the last ten
years then doing the national last year
with my little guy and my best friend
Brandon who I did card shows with I am
when I tell you I'm devastated that the
Nationals not happening this year and
it's in Atlantic City New Jersey I'm
crushed
I mean I'm crushed I think they push to
the December but I'm worried about that
you know so there's a lot of ways to go
about it but I think the Internet has a
great community obviously you can get
contentious with people selling versus
collecting and you know I'm sure you've
seen all that you know but uh but I
think um you know obviously your
consistency of being in the hobby will
probably be looked upon in a very good
way to that group and and uh and but but
eBay is a very fluid and very strong
market yeah okay well thank you very
much my pleasure Alex and I wish you
nothing but the best
appreciate you have any Jay Buhner
rookie cars I probably do yeah I've got
a couple take care yourself good man
take care all right such a good deal
Daniel hey Jerry how are you I'm well
how are you I'm doing really well thank
you what can I help you first I just
wanted to start off with the cliche
gratitude but for real like so I'm
following you about three or four years
ago not only have you dramatically
helped with mindset shifts but I also
started picking up these at about $15 a
piece bought about 150 of them Wow
yeah really you really listened I really
listened yeah once I'm glad that well
I'm glad I listened on the record
there's gonna be there's gonna be guys
that I'm excited about that are not
gonna work out that well so please I
know that's an all-time hit
please don't uh don't expect those kind
of returns from some other things I like
no no but with the thank you we just had
our first baby in the last year and it
has allowed us freedom it's allowed me
to subsidize all my lifestyle so like
it's just [ __ ] amazing what you've
been able to help with so really thank
you makes me have so happy you know it's
so funny every you know so many people
in the card world are like you're
ruining it you're doing this bad stuff
and you had your this kind of
conversation will really helps a human
beings life and like and when I know
that it was the things that people think
I'm ruining it for too many people
coming in all that was happening anyway
right you know so like knowing that you
listened to my content before I say hey
I really think this Lucca thing what's
the raw what are the raw look Lucas
going for now I sold a few of them at
about 150 apiece
so I mean I text my money on that I'm
grading a few sitting out a bunch so
yeah it's been it's been unreal no Luca
Luca is one of the people I'm most
curious about because I could you know
all he has to do in this this format
that's coming out but the NBA is go ham
and stand stun a higher seed cuz he
dropped 40 each night and and then
you're gonna see just mass hysteria
absolutely yeah I believe it so anyway
nonetheless what can I help well my this
isn't my original question but I gotta
know what's your biggest best card flip
that you've done so far you know I
haven't flipped anything that's been the
other side I'm trying to think of what I
saw actually one of the worst was I sold
some guy like 60 Lucas national for like
70 bucks PSA 10s that are now 700 right
400 whatever they are I'm success yes so
I I went to the you know I I I haven't
sold anything you know I really I just
haven't I I believe too much and
everything I have the exact same problem
and I know that obviously you need more
money to come in to buy more but I just
see what you're saying and I have such a
hard time I love the buying and selling
my my Instagram is GM I flip I love
flipping but I'm actually selling it yes
and flipping it you know sometimes gets
a bad name but if you're doing it with
the right honor and doing the right
things like it's such a great great
great thing it's look it's learning
merchants
it's it's forever people did it with
sheep and rocks and um yeah I I don't I
don't know like I don't know um when I
would sell I mean deep at this point I'm
not buying a lot of modern I don't have
a lot of work with them Hardaway what's
your play with that when they go to $4
and you're a 500 are you selling
individually are you gonna sell us a lot
I might I might do that it's like a
surprise giveaway to like fans that are
just getting into like I don't you know
I might give that to my son I you know
if they get to being like $200 PSA tens
cuz just this is even bigger than I
thought and it gets crazy then I would
get juiced up I definitely want to sell
at the National like I said in the last
call like I mean I think I might do four
to five shows a year I don't it's more
enjoyable like it's kind of like garage
saling for me it's super enjoyable but
I'll never be able to move a lot of
inventory in that format I'm also
extremely conscious and concerned about
people thinking that I'm pumping and
dumping you know so let's do a lot so
like I respect that I understand where
people coming from so like you know
first I'm not trying to buy a like like
75s a lot of Devin Booker's but I could
I could I believe in him so much I
could've bought a thousand before I made
that put you know so I'm trying not to
buy a lot I'm I'm thinking the next time
I say something I'm gonna fully disclose
how many I have like when I talk about a
Cooney I had like 11 you know it's not
like like I'm not trying like I'm trying
to really thoughtfully think about how
do I have a place in his hobby because
because if I talk about something I'm
getting demonized so heavily and I don't
like that feeling and I don't want
people thinking that I have any bad
intentions so I'm just trying to think I
really don't know Daniel
but I know buying 500 Tim Hardaway
rookies you know is at 85 cents it's not
a bad thing like there's gonna be
something good for that you know like I
might do a keynote speech in Miami and
at the end you know like or I might do a
book signing and put 500 of them in
cases and let people take one you know
like I love the Hobby I love people
getting into hobby other people get into
it for the collecting so and the selling
like I don't judge I don't think I get
to the judge if you should be a flip
somebody who sells or
you're somebody who is a hobbyist so
that's how I say brother cool awesome an
awesome I appreciate it thank you did
you ask a question I'm already like Alex
oh my my question that was my original
question yeah what's your question you
kind of already asked me what the very
first person asked me like what's the
next wave but also like what are your
strategies for studying the market my
book the Pokemon market what are you
looking up right now it's trying to get
our education education I don't even
have a strategy education oh this is
what first edition means oh this is what
red and yellow cheeks mean education
education education education you know
along with that what do you think drives
through the demand in the Pokemon market
cuz like Luca could drop a triple-double
and his card goes up but China so it's
not playing anymore
Pokemon's a 90 billion our IP Star Wars
is a 60 billion dollar IP so besides
consumer demand like what else they're
always good there's only consumer demand
and now macro card demand is like in the
ethos and you've got an unlimited amount
33 year olds that grew up with looking
like what about pokemon cards oh [ __ ]
this is what it you know like you know
that kind of Magic the Gathering
you know you know is brewing like Black
Lotus like there's brewing there's you
know Garbage Pail Kids there's things
brewing for me Pokemon because of AJ and
because Lou little knew on my team and
Tyler they're so into it they're like
sucking me into it a little bit um I see
Luke awesome for sure
wrestling is super on my mind yeah yeah
I really I think wrestling is similar to
Pokemon and comic books Andre the
Giant's Andre a giant forever Hulk Hogan
the rock so I think there's something
there too and people that are really
interesting I really push towards
getting to wrestling cards if they want
to do a little bit of business like I
think it's a nice space okay I know
there's a few more there's the other
things the other reason Reed
the other thing I look for is things
that people don't see like weird things
like panini basketball stickers I think
are super interesting I'm trying to
figure that out
Oh cuz I see soccer stickers mattering
so does that bleed into as America comes
bigger on soccer and and all of a sudden
Messi and Ronaldo and all these are
sticker rookies does that mean that
basketball panini rookies are
interesting you know I have it but I've
never been really super hot on Marvel
cards right but I could see that getting
hot I've been fine dad let mean like I
for
like for 1970s like whole the whole
Incredible Hulk stickers there's some
interesting stuff I haven't really dug
in but like things that people don't see
I think promo cards like like there's a
there's just like there's as Charles
Barkley JMS 1986 like like card that you
know 85 excuse me that came out the year
before
like I'm very fascinated by cards that
were weird cards that were made before
the actual rookie right is the promo
Michael Jordan like stuff like that I
absolutely love that that card is super
cool and that's a Nike card and if you
think about it right like if a lot of
people come in if this becomes super big
hobby why would a flea a rookie why
would a flea a rookie in 86 be better
than a Nike rookie in 85 like so that's
right that's what I'm trying to figure
out what's this like if you told me in 7
years that's worth more than the 86
floor that would not with the population
that wouldn't confuse me like so those
are things I'm looking for just trying
to figure [ __ ] out there's a yeah
there's there's a there's a haze 68
jack-in-the-box card
I like the 1972 I see Slurpee basketball
cards a lot so I think the weird [ __ ]
has a real big potential just cuz of
supply right so that's one look at us I
wish you well thank you so much for your
time man Kevin I do thinks I do I do
think UFC cards have a shot I think UFC
cards have a real [ __ ] shot I think
UFC and eSports kit cards are gonna be
in 20 years very interesting to debate
very interesting I know nothing about
them let's keep it going
big shot it's everybody on Twitch by the
way hey alright sweetie Wow just like
Tyler from Arkansas nice to meet you
brother alright so yeah I'm just so
nervous excited man I'm I've been
following you for a while now but it's
just surreal seeing you here it's like
having another make-a-wish happen but
yeah I've been in the sport oh yeah
sorry
alright so I've been into sports cards
for a while now I've been getting into
baseball real big cuz I mean my fiance
that's the one sport she said that
she'll actually go and watch it with me
so I said that's a big class I'll
definitely get into that
I mean I learned that Mike Trout
actually work worked with the travelers
down here in Arkansas so that was
awesome I've been getting big into that
made over 500 bucks on sports cards
already so I mean on disability that
helps out quite a bit
I've even you know thought about with
all the other sports cards I've had that
you know are worth like nothing you know
you buy packs all the time and you have
these other cards that are worth like a
penny and stuff I've been thinking about
building like my own like storage units
for it like I've been gluing together
the cards with like Marge Marge
with the different players and
everything that's really dude that's
really clever yeah and then I mean I'm
not gonna sell them I'm just gonna go
around and give them to some of these
other youtubers for free because I've
been watching like up north collectors
and pac-man and jabs family he's another
guy that I love watching especially you
I mean I don't have too many football
cards I'd love to get some Jets cards to
make one for you as well but listen yeah
team up with Dustin I'm gonna buy you a
box of football cards send it to you
hopefully you pull something great and
then what the commons you build
something sweet all right yeah that'll
work
yeah gives me plenty of time ya know is
about to gets that what I was wondering
is you're really awesome at watching
these players you don't just watch their
stats you like watch their whole life
and what they're doing you really
capture like their motivation and run
after that but um what are some of like
the baseball players that you're going
after that you feel aren't really
getting enough attention yet the one
player I'm very fascinated by so I
listen I think hakuna is an all-time
talent but I think his prices are in
certain place baseball's tough because
like first of all I think there's a lot
of players I think Francisco Lindor is
underpriced cuz I just akiza's such a
great player and a great dude
honey always has my attention I'm a very
big very big fan of Juan Soto as an
actual baseball player and so I think
that will play out well you know so
those are some of the kids that I think
are really interesting I haven't I
haven't truly
truly gone crazy yet on on baseball like
and I think baseball you know I'm just
so deep right now into basketball
focused wise and and and wrestling and
and and so but baseball is ironically
the sport I know the most of because um
because I play very hardcore fantasy
baseball so I have a I have a deep
knowledge of like Adly rush but you know
like and all this you know all the kids
are coming up like and so it's it's
interesting but sotto sotto I think is
super charismatic confident kid so he's
not inexpensive which is the problem I
don't have a real dark horse sleeper you
know what I mean no I got you do you
have any old legends you're looking out
for because I know a Mark McGwire was
one that popped up real fast not that
long ago I'm so much more passion about
vintage basketball than I'm vintage
baseball that's kind of where I'm at no
that's fine yeah yeah I got some
basketball too I've got some I got some
RJ Berry's iron Williamson I've been
trying to get into that too I mean you
know it's a ski far less is one of the
top ones it's expensive listen to me
yeah thanks for life and if you have
your girl interested in baseball and
you're interested in baseball there'll
be plenty of business opportunity in
baseball and it seems for you a lot of
life happiness you don't to force it in
places that don't excite you just cuz
there's money in it you need to be happy
and win and I think baseball has plenty
of stuff and by the way I'm gonna do my
fantasy baseball draft now in a couple
weeks and I have a very funny feeling
when I study for that for a week
hardcore that I'm gonna come out of that
excited about some baseball stuff you
know just it's living life you know I'll
be watching for that
alright brother I wish you well yeah
take care you as well I don't see bye
bye mr. bun it's a nice morning
Adrienne big Gary Vee I knew it man Tim
thanks for having me on thank you for
being on put on disconnect shirts let's
go the 94 the 94 Stanley Cup is the high
sports like my first that was
was the best finals ever pablor Pavel
Bure was my favorite non Ranger and you
can imagine what the night I mean Pavel
burries penalty shot
against the Rangers against Richter I
look I don't know if I've ever been more
nervous in a 45 second span in my entire
life
that's crazy is it true I heard on the
podcast you were at Game seven and
Madison is that that's crazy that's
crazy it's really the highlight of my
life it really really is that's awesome
so I got in the sports card when I found
you about six months ago you were
talking about tick tock and you were
like write about everything then you
started talking about getting into you
know buying Yanis cars for like a buck
forty and in selling like so I'm like
okay well maybe I should like take a
look at sports cars from when I
collected them you know at sixteen that
kind of thing so I jumped right in and
you're right you had to do a ton of
research yes and I thought I would spend
you a couple hundred bucks but when I
started looking at graded cards a couple
hundred bucks didn't really you know
take you that far so I kind of blew you
know like my budget right there so my
question for you is if you have a
limited budget you know under a thousand
five hundred bucks or something would
you rather go ninety-nine percent of
people and which is the whole yeah my
whole life yeah so would you rather go
great at cards or would you rather buy
raw and ungraded and try and grade them
because I kind of learned in this kind
of like journey that buying Ron ungraded
you almost need a skill to almost
regrade them so there's a real risk
reward thing or or you buy raw and you
sell it raw the gentleman a couple of
moments ago right bought luca's for
fifteen raw and selling them for a
hundred fifty so just sell them raw so
don't even try and greet them if you
don't want to put in the time to learn
and everything what I would say learn
but yeah let someone you don't have a
lot of money and you want to make more
money - both for your own health of your
family or because you want to fund your
hobby because you want to buy some you
know bjur a PSA ten rookie is because
you decided then you need to you need to
build up slowly and I think raw - raw is
the easiest way to build up slowly right
and if you've got a budget would you
rather
go established players which you kind of
like look because I know you've talked
about can like 80/20 where you're really
taking a risk with like yes you know
first of all Sports is a gamble like
they could get hurt yeah you could be
all excited about jaren Jackson jr. but
if he gets hurt the markets gonna be
soft yeah well that's what I mean I
bought couple like like Kobe Bryant
rocky cars but you always knew with like
Hall of Fame that was almost like
guaranteed even nothing's guaranteed but
it was almost guaranteed to go up
alright let me say this nothing's
guaranteed but it's like buying real
estate in Manhattan or buying like a
blue-chip fifty year company stock you
know it's gonna be very very very hard
for Kobe Bryant rookie cards to not be
worth more in twenty years it's gonna be
very hard yeah I mean I'm just gonna
hold onto mine for now but I mean mine
almost sold by mistake when I put it up
and come seem like I'm gonna put it up
like double the process no chance is
gonna sound any kind of soul and someone
bought it but I look when you have a
small budget which 99% people do you
need to do a lot of buying and selling
up you know little profits this is
literally how I build my first baseball
card business yeah I have no money
literally a dollar you know yeah just
been correct the money you have just
learn on ebay how to buy it how to sell
it and all that is just I mean all that
was just like new stuff to me so it's
just it's I guess is a good way to learn
awesome are you doing it I'm definitely
enjoying it it's just like I enjoy like
lots of different things and it was just
such a shock getting back into it from
like you know 90 how's my cards like you
know you think that it's it's like
completely different yeah yeah yeah
awesome yeah for sure it's definitely
enjoying for sure all right awesome Gary
see you later Keith Hopkins is killing
it today kind of soul that's right
though it's sold it's sold Matt how you
doing I'm well how are you I'm doing
well hey listen you got me back into
sports cards I try to think back and
said when did I last buy a baseball card
back then it was baseball cards and I
say probably when I was like
20 years old or something like that
maybe 15 so at a quick story for you
what I I looked in Providence I grew up
and brought her to her Island still in
Rhode Island and my uncle had a
typewriter shop where typewriters tell
you how far back it is right yeah
I'd me at 25 cents an hour I spy like
nine years older to help clean the
typewriters and do all that stuff and it
was about three blocks away no matter
how long I worked I always got at least
a buck or two so I would never go
straight home there was a candy store
that was right down a nice Street in
Providence and I would go there and
there was an old guy who would who ran
that store and if he wasn't open he
lived upstairs you'd go around the back
stairs knock on the door and say bill
can you open up cuz that money was burn
in my pocket and he'd go down open it up
and I'd go down and buy however many a
large TV good so you'd buy as much as
you could right up by as much as I could
and money never got home and I'd sit on
the front steps and open up the the
cards with the the pink bubble bubble
gum and stack those up for the week and
all that other stuff so but that's how
far back I go so I heard you talking
about sports cards and I said you know
look into this and I should look into I
said boy what a difference I mean
there's so much to know so I really
educated myself and now we got into and
I see one year old twin son and I do it
again we have a great time so we're at
the beach I was at the beach on Saturday
with my wife I get a text Reina who's a
soccer player they're trying to educate
me on soccer Reina just scored we have
this card right so it's just so much fun
to do it with them and we integrating
and so that's what I would tell you know
father's like hey listen you got a son
or a daughter even outside the
investments is probably hundred percent
Matt listen I'm a businessman I'm an
entrepreneur kid it's just who I am
everyone's different like of course the
business part is there for me it's
always been there for me but sports and
the hobby is a huge thing and the
friendship and the and the texting
branded at 1:00 in the morning and
saying hey what do you think about
your bias cuz he's a Cubs fan and like
I've talked to my brother AJ more this
week that I have in like a month because
it's not like business business it's
sports cards like it's it brings so much
joy I think it's a really good time but
one of the things that we that we got
together started investing is hops
project 2020 yes I got in around card 67
which bring the beginning and the print
runs are like 7,500 and then they just
and they were steady at that point and
then the market just the prices started
to explode just start really going up
and everybody kind of knew that way this
doesn't you know people were pre selling
and then a Griffey card came out it was
like the end of May and it sold like a
hundred thousand gonna glue the market
up and since then the markets just
trying to figure itself out prices and
totally you know crashed
what's don't I've been I've been people
been asking me left and right
like I didn't see how it launched you
know even hearing you say number 67 card
came like I don't even know there were
67 cards out I thought there's a lot
less it it's one of those feast or
famine things you know probably in 10
years the first 10 like the cliche I'm
completely under educated the cliche
thing that happens with sets like this
is the you know the first 10 15 in 10
years hold real value but you know I
these are kind of things that tend to go
up and then and then down
you think these are so there's 20
artists doing you know it's 20 cards
they'll be 400 and totally released to a
day these are baseball cards are they
works of art what I got their baseball
cards with with works of art DNA in them
so do you think there's one of the
thoughts was well this is bringing a lot
of people from outside who don't buy
baseball cards that's that's that's that
was happening before me obviously I had
a community that became aware of it like
you that there's gonna be this project
wait to somebody
really famous gets into it you know
giannis posted stuff about his own cards
weight to a famous rapper or you know
you know it's it's it the cats out of
the bag
it's like video games it's like it's
like any it's like sneakers it's like
anything else like cards have been this
is car you know people that are like in
the hobby a long time there was people
in the hobby you know that somebody said
to me Gary I've been the hobby you know
for 79 years 12 years 15 years I'm like
bro I get it I was in the hobby for 12
years back in the 80s like you know it
this is a this is a forever thing so
it's gonna happen flow I do think things
like project 2020 they're not the kind
of things that excite me
I'm not into art like that so that's one
I'm very excited for the artists you
know like good on them I'm I'm I hope
it's going great for them I'm happy for
the people that like iconic cards in
cool ways but for the people that are
looking at as an investment it's not the
place where I go to me it's older
rookies vintage basketball soccer it's
just not the place where I go but that
doesn't mean I'm right they may go 10 X
20 X 50 X you know I don't know I don't
know but like it doesn't feel for me
like the place that I would that I go
it's not where I go do you think there's
something that there's so if you have
the something that you would grade or
you just leave them I mean if they're
baseball do you think you're great um or
you don't bother grading home you just
leave them as they are
you know greetings a tricky game like to
me it's like you grade when you know
it's worth it for you so like maybe you
want to see how low they go and then
decide if you want to grade them okay
all right well good luck I wish you well
alright dear thank you everybody who uh
who uh who joined today a lot of fun
this is just like such an incredible
javi please leave a tweet with what you
thought about the show and I wish you
nothing nothing nothing but the best and
if you're just finding about cards now
like please hundred hours of education
this is not a get-rich-quick it's not a
gold rush it's so hot right now that
there's a lot of risk of going down at
some point but there is long-term
opportunity if you're educated and as
you can see there's so many nuances that
make it fun and so I hope you have fun
with it I hope you have a great weekend